this is a video that i have put together
in order to help students understand
what we call the qep or quality
enhancement plan that fayetteville state
university consists in
what their roles are what their faculty
members are going to be
doing over the next five years
how they fit into it and what it's
really all about
so i'm only going to go over some of the
broad outlines of the quality
enhancement plan
we're currently undergoing what's called
re-accreditation through
sas which is our reaccrediting
our accreditation agency
and that's an association of schools
they come in they look over all the
different aspects of
fayetteville state university
and then they determine what things we
need to fix what things we need to do in
order to improve student learning
one of the recent things that's been
added is you have to have a quality
enhancement plan
and that is designed to improve student
learning
and the thing that we decided to focus
on
this time around was critical thinking
that's where i come in
i am a professor of philosophy here at
fsu
and i teach critical thinking classes
i'm a subject matter expert on critical
thinking
i was involved in the writing of the
quality enhancement plan so i'm here to
talk to you
you students and also to a lesser extent
faculty
about what it is exactly that we're
doing so that people know
what to tell
sags people when they come in but also
so that we have a much better
understanding of where we're going over
the next
five to ten years
so the quality enhancement plan that we
we have in place
is has its acronym m-e-d-d making
evidence-based decisions
and that is really a function of
critical thinking
you can time other skills that are very
closely related like problem solving
sometimes you hear these talked about
his analytical reasoning
and there are a lot of different ways to
try to promote evidence-based decisions
not all of them necessarily involve
critical thinking classes as a matter of
fact what we want to do
is to promote critical thinking across
the curriculum we want to involve it in
a lot of different classes
and what we have to do we faculty and
the administrators also of fsu
with you students is we have to
demonstrate that we are actually
teaching you how to become
evidence-based decision makers that
we're actually improving
your performance your understanding your
abilities in these respects
so one of the things that
we should talk about at the start is how
are we going to do that
not only how are we going to promote it
how are we going to
put it into the classes but
really when it comes down to it how are
we actually going to demonstrate this
how are we going to prove to outside
people that you students
are actually making improvements
one of the devices that we're going to
be using for this is called the
for short the cla what that really means
are cla performance tasks
and what these are many of you students
have actually been introduced to these
at one point or another at this point
a cla performance task gives you a set
of documents which contain a mix of
pertinent
irrelevant and irrelevant sometimes even
misleading information there will be
arguments built into them you have to
compare the documents to each other you
have to exercise quite a few skills
using them and then you're provided with
a scenario that you take some sort of
position and somebody will be making
arguments and you yourself will have to
assess their arguments given the
evidence that you have
from the documents you'll have to make
your own arguments you'll have to tell
about the situation who should be
believed who shouldn't be believed
things along those lines for example one
of the clas that i designed and i've
used in classes and some of you students
may actually remember this
involve choosing
one
prison education policy or another
whether to go from four-year liberal
arts degrees
to two-year business degrees
and the goal was to reduce recidivism
and if you actually looked at all the
data that was provided all the documents
and you looked at it carefully you would
realize actually before your liberal
arts program was a better option but it
was set up in such a way that if you
weren't careful if you weren't a
critical thinker if you weren't making
evidence-based decisions you would get
misled so this is a way for us to
actually test whether
you're
exercising critical thinking abilities
one of the other things on the cla is it
requires you to write essay
responses and in those essay responses
not only do you have to make
evidence-based decisions you have to put
that down on paper you have to explain
what the evidence is
and why it constitutes good evidence and
if you do a really good response you
actually address possible
counter
positions other arguments that people
might make
so and these are the sort of things that
we ought to be teaching you in college
and we are trying to do that
so you will probably see a number of
different things coming into your
classes so now we've talked about how
we're actually going to measure this how
we're going to assess it
now the thing to think about as far as
the qep is
how is it going to impact you as a
student
well
one of the main points one of the main
parts i should say of the ceo of the qep
stumbling over all these acronyms aren't
that one of the main
points of the qep is faculty development
that means that your professors
are actually still learners at the same
time they are learning how to
incorporate new ideas and to become
better
teachers
and
there are five different tracks that
we're using
in this this program that doesn't mean
that these are the only ways of teaching
critical thinking or incorporating
critical thinking there are five tracks
that are part of our qep
one of them is what's called reading
across the curriculum
reading is very important to critical
thinking because if you're not a good
reader if you're not attentive if you're
not paying attention to what's going on
in a story a narrative in an argument
then you're gonna have a very difficult
time making any sort of reasonable
decisions about it so reading across the
curriculum incorporating a lot of
techniques this is one thing that we're
going to do the second one is writing
across the curriculum
this is another program that we've had
in place here at fsu for a while and
we're going to be
adding some new features to it focusing
very very closely on critical thinking
which means we're focused focusing very
closely on a particular kind of writing
writing to make arguments
writing to assess evidence writing to
incorporate information sources that is
all part of making evidence-based
decisions so
reading across the curriculum writing
across the curriculum a third one that
we're going to be doing is integrated
course design now we have actually done
some of this before
with our faculty development seminar
and
we're going to be doing it through
online courses some of which our faculty
have already been experimenting with
integrated course design means that what
we're doing is we're looking at the
course that you're taking as a student
as a whole we're trying to figure out
how to design it so that we're
maximizing your involvement your
engagement with the subject material how
do we reinforce
the things that you're learning how do
we give you more and more opportunities
to bring things together to synthesize
things and again that's supposed to make
you better evidence-based decision
makers if we design our courses well
you'll have more of those aha moments
where you see how things fit together
so that's three so far
the fourth one
is something tied in with our library we
have a very successful information
literacy program information literacy
ties in directly with us because where
is your evidence coming from
well your evidence is information
information literacy
means knowing several things means
knowing how to get information
how to get information that's a
good for what it is that you're studying
not just you know
popular sources or unreliable sources
but good scholarly sources on it it
involves evaluating information
determining whether the information that
you have is actually relevant to your
task
is actually
going to be providing you something
useful or whether it's misleading
whether there's bias built into it all
sorts of things are part of information
literacy
we have a program the chestnut library
fellowship that we we've gone through i
went through it myself and i can highly
recommend it
in information literacy where we study
what are called acrl standards for
information listening we incorporate
them into our classes
so now we've got four different tracks
for our qep
the fifth one is what we call cla of the
university that's based on the cla in
the classroom which won't mean all that
much to you
as students
unless you've actually encountered cla
performance tasks in your classes
a lot of us professors here at fsu
have had some sort of contact with the
collegiate learning assessment
we've started using it here at fsu for
institutional assessment with the rising
juniors and the entering freshmen so we
can see whether you're actually
developing critical thinking skills
and where are you
how far have you developed that
do we need to put more emphasis on these
sorts of things we've been acquiring
data about that
now we're going to be adding a third
step in the process the med
part is going to come in the majors
so in your major courses
you should see
some cla performance tasks
you're going to see these these
evidence-based
problems that you have to solve you're
going to do a number of them and then
before you graduate you're actually
going to have to take
some sort of
cla based exam a senior exit exam that
is also going to be part of our
our qep
now all these things tie in together
and they're all supposed to reinforce
each other the whole goal is to improve
your educational experience here at fsu
by focusing on what matters absolutely
the most
critical thinking
problem solving analytical reasoning and
also some of the component things like
reading and writing
you notice i'm not talking about things
like having a good time
the you know the college experience in
that sense why not well because you know
that will actually that's already
happening at fsu we really want you to
graduate from here with a solid sense of
how to make an argument how to take a
position how to provide evidence how to
provide good evidence not just saying
well i feel that this or that but to say
well here is what the information shows
let me articulate it for you that's what
we want for you that's what that's the
educational experience we want you to
come out of here having you know had
many opportunities to do that is what
our quality enhancement plan is about
and that is what saks is going to be
looking at us
this coming week to see whether we can
actually pull it off
we have
roughly five years to do it
you're going to see step by step these
things getting put in place so you can
see a lot of
interesting
engaging changes happening
over the next several years in your
curriculum
and you're going to see people walking
around with these name tags or badges
saying m-e-d
that means making evidence-based
decisions that is what our qep basically
focuses on
so i hope that this has been helpful for
you
if you have questions about this you can
email me at
gsadler uncfsu.edu
and
i can give you some further information
if there's some need for follow-ups on
this i will post additional youtube
videos
and
there we go i think this is a great
program i think that this is really
going to
improve education at fsu
and i hope that you'll
you students will engage with it and
find it useful and i hope that you
faculty that are watching this will take
the opportunity to get involved with
this because i think this is a really
great plan